[Music]
of course your your very successful now
you get you've got a fans or developing
a great following but you've you always
had kind of jobs on the side to pay the
bills is that right well year for a
while I had to have some odd jobs I
taught piano and I was a mask maker for
a while and then asked me yeah and then
I was also a sandcastle-building
instructor that's a real thing I didn't
know it existed until I got the job but
but yeah where was this is it it was at
a hotel in Santa Monica
okay it's like an upscale hotel and then
they want you to teach kids or something
how to make it exactly but most of the
time nobody showed up so I'd just hang
out on the beach but I actually I have
to tell you something I kind of have a
confession to tell you well one day I
was sculpting this face and I looked at
it and I was like you know this face
looks a lot like Conan O'Brien and and
so I I like sculpted your face and your
body in the sand I like made the hair
and the whole thing in you and I had a
really lovely day on the beach together
[Applause]
and you have is this what you brought
some pictures this you really did this
you had someone take pictures yeah let's
take a look oh there's I'm putting
suntan lotion on you cuz you're pale and
I want to look out great accurate yeah
we're drinking some wine making some
wine and I'm apparently passed out drunk
yeah I'm reading Elle magazine I don't
know what's up with Jennifer Aniston
yeah and I'm like face I made yeah
here what I noticed halfway through the
interview that there's a ukulele right
next to me is this fear for a reason
because I actually after our romantic
day I wrote a song about it because this
is it got how should I play it for you I
mean I you can you wrote about our day
if it's together
the sad part is he got washed away so I
was a little bit lonely and I'll never
be the same but here goes ready sure
Conan O'Brien in the sand I think I fell
in love with the most handsomest man I
sculpted his hands in his hair and his
hands and then he washed away Oh Conan
Conan O'Brien at the shore I don't think
that could ever really ask for much more
we stayed on the beach till a quarter of
4 and then he washed away
Oh Conan you made my heart beat subside
it was my mistake
I built you close to the tide and I'm
very sorry
do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do Gonen Conan
O'Brien preach the waves took you away
now that I'm alone on the beach some say
that love is a figure of speech unless
that love is true so there is one thing
to do
I'll sculpt you again
[Applause]
it's so nice
[Applause]